[Music]
serious thousand apologies hate when
people are tardy it's good to meet you
boys
thanks for coming out use mass spec
before you got here did you
what don't work with my buddies caring a
lot of weapons [ __ ] this Montauk place
I'm gone there you're on a different
level now guy you represent this
merchandise and lawns bigger than your
whole [ __ ] country
Justine has gorgeous is Ava where you
puttin up with a white [ __ ]
check out too much that's not what he
ordered [ __ ] really
you ordered m16 different weapon I'm not
runnin a [ __ ] beat the delivery
service keep your [ __ ] together you want
the weapons or you don't want the weapon
here we go now we're cooking
Wheelock city without man and I'm sure
that you boys who talk to me with the
way pocket okay
[Applause]
[Music]
- Peters bring a sniper the last word a
[ __ ] rain look like whoa [ __ ]
hey party Marty come on man I like it
God brought armor the fiction prose
fiction tell me who hired you right now
when Judas checked him and Hanif what -
[ __ ] you they can't all be wrong
[ __ ]
you